So when we reason inductively, we often make causal inferences. And a causal
inference is simply when we decide that one thing causes another. So for
example, when I go on a vacation, I always get sick. And implicit in this
statement, is a causal inference. And the causal inference is that vacations
causes me to get sick. Now, when we use inductive reasoning and causal
inferences, we sometimes fall prey to what's known as confirmation bias. And
confirmation bias is when we seek out information and pay attention to
information that confirms our already held beliefs, and we dismiss and ignore
information that dis-confirms, or contradicts, our beliefs. So for example,
when you're writing a paper, do you actually look for information that
dis-confirms and contradicts your thesis? Or do you write about and pay
attention to only that information that confirms your ideas? Yeah, I thought
so. You know, many of us do this. But next time you're writing a paper, try
this. Try to integrate, both confirming and disconfirming evidence. It'll make
for a stronger paper. Which actually leads to our next topic, Critical
Thinking.